disturbing images of a mass arrest in
Northern
Gaza at least 100 Palestinian men are
seen stripped down to their underwear
blindfolded and made to
kneel and un identified voice in Hebrew
can be
heard it's not known where they have
been taken the first thing jumped in my
mind when I saw the pictures the second
world war to be honest with you how they
treated you know detes and those they
were arrested or prisoners of War that's
the case I think the this any human uh
this is a torture it amount to torture
and uh more than that uh it's a war
crime and the crimes against humanity
Israel is describing them as suspected
Fighters but an increasing number of
civilians have now been identified one
of them is Palestinian journalist Dia Al
khut he's a correspondent for the AL
Arabi aljadid newspaper and website it
says several members of his family are
among those detained has a disabled
daughter and a very old mother so
logistically it was very unpractical and
he decided to stay we identified him
amongst those detained we also
identified at least two kids under the
age of 16 both of them were 15y old and
we identified two employees of the
United Nations onra schools and we
identified at least three elderlies Dia
is one of dozens of journalists
currently imprisoned by Israel human
rights groups say Israeli abuse of
prisoners is widespread and systemic and
there are now concerns about this latest
group taken in Gaza Dem Khan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer